we have a major story tonight this may
have some significa historical
significance the Georgia D.A published
the indictments against Donald Trump
while the grand jury is still in session
they have not convened yet they have not
come to determination yet somehow
Reuters got a hold of the charges
already
the Assumption here is the D.A in
Georgia obviously anti-trump already
knows what they're charging him with and
the grand jury for show
it's a trick now many are calling for
Trump to file a lawsuit motion to
dismiss on constitutional grounds that
this is well it's tainted
I mean this is shocking earlier today I
tweeted out the story from Reuters
breaking news they're set to charge
Trump the documents have been released
and then shortly after they removed
those documents and said whoops
but they're already planning on a dining
and we'll talk about that